哈囉我是小三雷
今天想給你們分享一下
我個人修護平障的經驗
這些是我以前的臉過得高雲紅
是持續了兩年度
我之前的一次區皮膚診素
我皮膚檢測
就是那個V3
醫生總是說我的臉價太薄了
到2021年我才徹底的把我這個高雲紅給解決了
我沒有用任何的要物
我就是一直在嚴州這個護膚
那這是我現在的臉
我現在沒有擦任何的護膚品
我兩家這個高雲紅
就是徹底的已經好了
不管摸它怎麼樣都不會紅了
那我今天並不是要跟你們分享
我是用了什麼護膚品
我相信你們已經來了一堆了
我為什麼他總是恢復不好
那我現在來跟你們說一下
我覺得修護平障最重要的是什麼
是解面
因為在解面方面出了問題
每天皮膚好不容易恢復
長得那一點皮膚平障
被你一起又給洗掉了
他的身長的速度沒有你破壞他的速度快
所以你一直感覺反反不服
就是晚上擦一個修護類的
護膚品睡覺感覺
臉這個飯紅又好很多
但是現完妝洗完臉洗個早
你出來又發現臉
變成這種紅豐豐的樣子了
那我跟你們說兩個洗面來成分
一個是ABG
一個是甜菜檢
這兩個表活
這個是我當年做了一系列的
功課之後發現了兩個神仙的表活
這兩個表活都非常的溫和一般是做附配
比如ABG附配安靜酸洗面來
這個就比單獨的安靜酸洗面
哪要更加溫和洗一致不洗溫
安靜酸它其實並不是最溫和的洗面來成分
那我當時也是比較懶
我當時去做了功課找到了兩款
非常溫和的檢面之後
我就是一直用下去
一款是這個
我記得我當時皮膚平障的時候
換成用它洗臉之後
一周把我的臉就不紅了
我現在手裡都沒有
因為我現在用的是另一款檢面
但是如果你們對它感興趣
你們可以去查一下它的成分表
它是我發現的市面上來說最溫和的一款檢面
不過你現在臉
就是超級無敬敏感的那種
那你現在就是停止一切的洗面來
只用清水洗臉
如果實在是想要用一款洗面來
你就用這個大豆檢面
那還有一款就是這個
它應該在我的視頻裡面出現過很多次
只跟你們說我喜歡它
因為它很溫和
但是我沒有跟你們說過它為什麼溫和
它就是ABG附配安靜酸洗面
我當時是用它用了一個多月的樣子
在配合一些修護的護服品
我的高渴紅就好了
一直到現在我也還是用的
它我的臉價一直都很好
沒有在邊緩高渴紅了
那它和那個大豆檢面
都是有一個共同的缺點
就是它們的洗膠不好
它就是它像這種比一替一樣
是這種低泡洗了檢量
所以很多品牌都喜歡用這兩個成分
因為大部分的檢量都是對於洗面
奶的泡泡是非常的执著的
所以這個是不符合大眾的洗澡的
但是我覺得只要是能夠對皮膚好
我就不管它是洗乾好不好
因為我是一個油豆皮碼
我平時是喜歡用一些膜藥的
所以我對結面的腰球就是一定要溫和
因為我需要一個健康的皮膚平常去耐受那些膜藥
就我有一個朋友
它的臉就是紅到像那個血人娃娃一樣的
它之前是每個月都要去做那個MQQ去紅
但是都沒有用
然後我一問它起來
裡面居然有五種造肌成分
那你用這個洗面奶洗臉
臉不紅就怪了
它直接去醫院了一聲給它看了一個身長因子
它在配合一些溫和的結面
它還有幾天它的那個高油紅就好很多很多
那你們可以關注我一下
下期視頻我跟你們講修護平常的一些其他的注意事想